this tiny model of Rodin's thinker was
3d printed using light materialized in a
cylinder of liquid resin conventional 3d
printers deposit material layer by layer
gradually building up the structure but
this new approach developed by
researchers in California materializes
entire objects at once
there are searches that created the
machine nicknamed the replicator were
inspired by CT scanners during a CT scan
two-dimensional x-ray images are taken
of a patient from many different angles
these slices are then reconstructed to
form a 3d model well the researchers
thought why not run the process in
Reverse they used a program to
reverse-engineer 2d images from many
angles around a 3d model in this case
the thinker then they could composite
all the slices into a video sequence
next they fill the cylinder with a
synthetic resin which solidifies in
contact with certain intensities of
light by projecting the video onto the
cylinder and rotating the cylinder in
time the slices are reconstructed in the
resin as it solidifies after about two
minutes the thinker is born the waste
liquid can then be washed away leaving
only the printed object the researchers
have printed more than just the thinker
they hope that this technique could one
day be used to create bespoke medical
pieces like this replica of a jaw as the
process relies on solidification rather
than deposition of materials it allows
objects to be printed which enclose
existing ones like the handle of this
screwdriver the surface is also
completely smooth which is helpful when
manufacturing optical parts at the
moment the machine is limited to
centimeter scale objects and has some
work to do to finesse the forms but this
is a totally new way to 3d print and
it's one which offers some interesting
possibilities